[Musique]
salut je m'appelle nicolas
j'ai 30 ans et à 10 ans j'étais comme
vous j'ai été étudiant je passais mes
journées assis sur une chaise a coûté un
professeur en espérant qu'un jour un
métier qui me plaisent je puisse réussir
ma vie
et des fois je me demandais aussi mais
qu'est-ce que je n'étais pas que j'avais
plein de rêves je rêvais de découvrir le
monde et peut-être j'ai trouvé ma place
et puis finalement mes rêves j'ai un peu
oublié
je rentrais dans les rangs j'ai trouvé
un boulot je suis j'avais une routine
tout ça et puis un jour cette pensée est
revenue en moi vraiment au plus profond
de moi-même et genève mais qu'est ce que
je fous là
et à ce moment là il ya une pensée qui
est venu dans ma tête une seule pensée
s'est passé c'est tellement vous attache
à ce moment là mon coeur saigne à battre
la chamade tout mon corps s'est mis à
vivre et pompon waouh
voyage voyage voyage je me sentais
vivant je me sentais but précoce je
m'étais pas senti vibrer depuis si
longtemps
c'est comme si j'étais tombé amoureux
alors là je me suis dit waouh c'est
tellement fort ça il faut il faut que je
passe quelque chose qu'est ce que je
peux faire je sais pas mais je vais
essayer
je vais essayer je vais je vais dédier
ma vie à cette force qui me fait vibrer
cette force que j'appelle l'intuition
à ce moment là je n'avais plus qu'une
chose à faire j'ai démissionné j'ai
quitté mon nom mon logement et j'ai fait
tenir ma vie dans un sac à dos je suis
parti à l'aventuré pour vivre un été de
folie
tout a commencé là on était une
quinzaine de personnes sur des radeaux
fait entièrement de matthaüs ont reçu
que les réutiliser récupérer des
poubelles pour prouver qu'on peut encore
faire des voyages de manière
complètement écologique et ans a enlevé
cette aventure pendant un mois en
espagne sur une rivière de manière
complètement illégal on veut c'est ce
qu'on voulait elle avait aucune règle
aucune limite moi je me sentais comme un
vrai pirate
c'était génial et cette expérience a
fait naître un rêve en moi je suis dit
pourquoi pas prolonger cette expérience
et vivre sur l'eau comme un marin comme
du temps des grandes explorations
était à continuer
allez
dans un rassemblement à repenser à ces
endroits où on vient au milieu de la
forêt pour se nourrir d'amour suis en
droit c'est le seul moment où moi je
peux faire mon yoga tout nu en chantant
démontra indien et tout le monde trouve
ça normal et j'étais là un soir au coin
du feu a discuté avec un mec d'une
anecdote que j'avais entendu ça y paraît
qui est des mecs ils vont aux canaries
et faune du bateau stop et et des fois
il arrive à trouver un bateau et
traverse l'atlantique en voilier
c'est complètement fou et je rigole pas
j'étais là avec le mec est une fille qui
se retourne une fille que je ne
connaissais pas du tout quoi ça
t'intéresse de traverser l'atlantique en
voilier
parce que moi je veux le faire et
peut-être que le capitaine il ya une
place pour toi tiens je vais écrire le
numéro de capitaine si tu veux beaucoup
popopopop whaou tu vois ça tu me
l'aurait mis dans un film n'aurait pas
trouvé ça crédible et pourtant si ce qui
m'arrivait et là je me suis dit funes
est complètement fou ouais ouais aller
sur l'eau un voilier tout ça je reviens
en ville j'appelle le capitaine il me
dit rendez vous dans trois mois aux
canaries et c'était parti c'était parti
pour deux mois deux mois sur un voilier
avec ses hauts et ses bas toutes les
difficultés de vivre au milieu des
éléments air fois cette joie d'avoir
autour de soi une vue à 360° de voir les
étoiles et de prendre le temps de voyage
et de prendre le temps d'être avec les
éléments pendant ce voyage on est passé
des canaris au cap vert jusqu'en
martinique et j'ai passé 13 jours treize
jours sans voir le moindre parcelle de
terre sans voir de l'âme humaine que
ceux qui m'accompagnent leur bateau et
ça psychologiquement c'était très très
dur nous qui avait ses moments durs mais
à la fois je vous montrer quelque chose
qui était fantastique quand on navigue
sur l'atlantique c'est pour prendre sa
douche
qu'en pense à ta bouche soit tandis que
ça ressemble à ça
à défaut sa fille m'a fallu y aller pour
un looping en bateau on t'aurait looping
mois
ça y est
donc après après deux mois sur la mer
j'arrive à en martinique les caraïbes
cet endroit sur terre où il fait
toujours chaud et là je peux vivre tout
bon une fois d'enseignement en tee shirt
tout le temps et enfin j'arrive à me
guérir de cette sinusite que j'avais
depuis que j'étais petit enfin j'avais
plus froid c'était génial je passe deux
mois en martinique avant d'avoir envie
de bouger
et puis je vais au port pour voir s'il
ya peut-être des annonces et là je tombe
sur un petit mot jeune skipper cher
coéquipiers pour aller à kariat cariacou
je n'avais aucune idée que c'était mais
j'avais mon quart qui tremblaient vent
en poupe pour compte propre ou bon ben
je sortais super vibrer j'appelle le mec
il me donne rendez vous le lendemain et
on part pour kayak où on arrive pile
poil pour le carnaval
alors le carnaval c'est la fête du
printemps mais dans lé sud caraïbes
là où j'étais on l'a on la célèbre d'une
manière particulière alors toute la nuit
recettes de la peinture et en danse
derrière des murs d'enceinte
mais on n'en fait pas n'importe quoi
donc là où j'étais en tout cas on danse
la soca pour ceux qui savent pas ce que
c'est que la se classer une danse très
conviviale
je vous montrais donc il ya la fille qui
devant comme ça et là le mec derrière
comme ça c'est génial qu'est ce qu'on
s'est amusé moi j'ai passé un super
moment
le mono mains du carnaval je retrouve
une fille qui est qui m'a vite sur l'île
de grenade et je les retrouve là avec
son compagnon et ses deux enfants
on devient vite amis et avec cette
petite famille
j'apprends à vivre sur les caraïbes il
m'invite chez eux et vous voyez cette
petite famille vivait dans dix mètres
carrés alors je sais pas si vous savez
ce que c'est que dix mètres carrés mais
pour avoir vu leurs titres maison
voilà ça ressemble à ça c'est la place
où tu peux mettre un lit deux places
avec des vêtements une gazinière et un
couloir grand comme ça et alors c'était
surprenant que cette famille de leurs
dix mètres carrés et est très heureuse
ok c'est les caraïbes il fait toujours
chaud leur jardin c'était la nature tout
autour mais en attendant cette famille
elle savait se satisfaire de ce que
c'est ce qu'elles avaient elles savaient
apprécier ce qu'elle avait ça c'est une
valeur que j'ai appris avec eux et
durant tout mon voyage en découvrant
tant que culture c'est que on peut se
satisfaire de ce qu'on a même se
satisfaire de paiement tca apprécié ce
qu'on a au lieu de toujours vouloir plus
après ça j'ai pris votre bateau je suis
allé à trinidad et puis je suis arrivé
au venezuela enfin j'ai pu faire mon
voyage écologique pur j'ai pu arriver
desquels des oeuvres de l'europe
jusqu'aux amériques un peu comme
christophe ans donc ça m'a pris six mois
mais alors moi j'ai relevé mon déficit
est si content bon le venezuela c'est un
peu le bordel je suis tanné en colombie
et en colombie j'ai découvert une
nouvelle famille cette famille c'est les
gens qui comme moi vivent et voyages
pour vivre leur passion
ce sont des musiciens des jongleurs des
artisans partout où ils vont ils
déploient leur art ils le montrent et le
vent divin peu d'argent avec continuer
leur voyage et cette nouvelle famille
ils m'apprennent affaire le cema follow
semafo l'eau en français c'est le feu
rouge alors moi je me mets devant le feu
rouge avec ma balle je fais mon
spectacle pendant que les voitures
attendent et puis avant que le feu passe
au vert je passe trop chapeau et puis
une voiture par et je continue comme ça
et pour la première fois de ma vie je
pouvais gagner ma vie honnêtement en
faisant ce qui me plaît et ça c'était
une véritable révolution pour moi ce
mode de voyage
ce mode de spectacle jeulin portes en
europe continuant rives de temps en
temps et c'est vraiment génial j'ai
continué mon voyage
j'ai descendu et j'ai envie d'aller dans
l'amazonie vous savez dans l'amazonie il
ya tous ces peuples indigènes avec leur
culture qu'on connaît pas forcément et
qui sont parfois ils sont obscures et y
avait aussi ces fameux rituel à base de
plantes sacrées qui nous sont très
mystérieuse pour nous et voyez il ya
quelque chose que j'ai appris là bas
c'est que ya pas mal de plantes qu'on
utilise chez nous dans nos sociétés qui
créent des maladies et même la mort je
parle du tabac mais pas que et bien dans
cette culture on sait utiliser ces
plantes non pas pour me créer des
maladies mais pour guérir exactement
l'opposé
alors je me suis dit peut-être que nous
a vendu 10 et plantons devons pourrait
apprendre de ces cultures des traditions
pendant que eux apprennent de nos
technologies et de notre science
peut-être que ça ça me paraissait être
un défi pour le 21e siècle
j'ai passé plusieurs semaines dans la
forêt avant d'avoir envie de changer
d'air et moustiques j'en avais un peu
marre
et puis j'avais un rêve c'était de faire
un trek en solitaire alors je suis parti
au centre du pérou près de huaraz pour
monter à plus de 4000 mètres d'altitude
mon défi c'était de monter seul dépasser
4000 mètres et même de dépasser les 5000
m donc après celle là on était à 4006 et
puis moi j'ai postulé à monter jusqu'à
5000 et là j'ai découvert un silence
silence si pur si beau autour de moi à
360 degrés et puis j'ai des cols j'étais
par cette si belle solitude m'a la fois
ci présentent parfois moi je fais le
choix de toujours voyez seul parce que
je voyage pour me connaître et mieux
connaître le monde mais à la fois je
sais que quand cette solitude me pèse
c'est qu'il est temps d'aller retrouver
ce qu'ils me comprennent
et ce qui me comprennent ce qu'ils
vivent comme moi je sais où les trouver
on appelle ça une rave party une fête
trance psychédélique appelez le comme
vous voulez mais c'est un endroit où on
vient pour danser ensemble sur musique
électronique sortir comme une tribu
comme nos ancêtres à danser autour du
feu ensemble on partage des valeurs de
joie d'harmonie de paix en somme on veut
célébrer la connexion avec la vie avec
la nature avec l'univers peut-être qu'on
peut prendre des produits psychédélique
mais pas pour fuir l'arrêter mais pour
mieux la connaître pour mieux se
connaître
et puis dans cette troupe de fou il y a
cette fille française
andy et nicholas tu veux quand rentrer
en france je te vends mon camion géant
camion ouais ouais j'avoue là j'en ai un
peu marre des gens sac à dos c'est un
rêve de gosse ça mais alors rentré
j'étais parti avec la ferme conviction
que que je rentre que je rentre pas ça
m'intéressait pas mais était possible
que je ne rentre pas et là je commence à
me dire ah ouais pourquoi pas mais alors
je suis pas du tout prêt
j'étais pas près j'étais voyage ou âgées
depuis des mois mais j'étais allé au
bout de ce que je cherchais alors que
coûte c'est continuer je me suis mieux
encore au défi de traverser le brésil en
stop alors le brésil non stop c'est une
catastrophe et que les camionneurs qui
me prenait j'étais sous 40° avec mon
chapeau aux gars c'était très dur mais
voilà j'ai réussi à rejoindre
l'atlantique et vous voyez là plus
heureux que jamais j'avais la liberté
enfin j'étais arrivé j'avais trouvé ce
que j'étais venu chercher je faisais ce
que je voulais quand je voulais j'avais
la liberté de sourire le bien-être mais
alors j'avais une grande confusion en
moi tous les soirs je ne dormais pas je
ne peux pas fermer l'oeil j'avais trop
d'idées trop de vision j'avais tous mes
rêves pour le futur quand je rentrerai
tous les soirs dans ma tête j'en vendais
des symphonies des musiques écrivait des
livres les films des scénarios tout
plein de choses j'avais plus qu'une
chose à faire c'était revenir pour
l'appliquer alors voilà survenu j'ai
fini par acheter un camion pour voyager
et continuer à partager ma passion j'ai
commencé à composer de la musique à
jouer dans des festivals
j'ai commencé à écrire un livre qui
était publié mois dernier j'ai commencé
à faire des conférences pour partager ce
que j'ai vécu
et puis partout où je vais chez mon
spectacle avec ma balle magique pour
émerveiller les petits et les grands
et ensemble et c'est de dire qu'on peut
s'émerveiller de la vie en ralentissant
et après sur les choses simples et puis
j'ai même organisé mes propres concerts
les concerts on vient pour se détendre
sans dormir ici même à toulouse
et enfin je me sentais à ma place je me
sentais utile échoué ce qui me plaisait
mais je vous avoue tout ça je l'aurais
jamais fait ces moments de mon village
je n'aurais pas fait une retraite de
méditation
on appelle ça puis pas sanaa
la vision pénétrante si nous retraite de
dix jours pendant laquelle on ne parle
pas pendant dix jours on passe huit
heures par jour les yeux fermés assis à
observer tout ce qui se passe en soi à
prendre conscience de tout ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur
chaque pensée chaque sensation
chaque émotion on observe sans prendre
part au processus on observe tout ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur
je vous avoue dix jours comme ça ça crée
des déclics
pour la première fois je voyais vraiment
les idées claires j'avais vraiment une
grande lucidité sur moi même et j'avais
réalisé que je fuyais quelque chose dans
ma vie c'est ce qui m'a permis de
revenir et enfin d'être sédentaire et
d'accepter d'être sédentaire présent je
vais vous demander de regarder les deux
prochaines diapositives dans le silence
voyez ça
c'est ce qu'on a tous probablement été
un jour dit
petit bébé innocent naïve prêt à tout
vivre près à tout exploré prêt à tout
pardonner
et ça c'est qu'on sera tous probablement
un jour
moi en voyant ça je
sion qu'est ce qui compte vraiment
qu'est ce qui compte
la réponse que j'ai trouvé c'est qu'au
moment où je meurs j'ai envie de pouvoir
me dire j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
mais ça c'est que ma réponse s'en fout
ma réponse y foncez vous trouvez votre
propre réponse en accord avec qui vous
êtes
et j'ai pas
c'est là
pas ce silence particulier
propre à l'introspection quand on se
pose des questions profondes
quand on est là ensemble
même
voulait pas noyé par les pensées du
à essayer de se battre ensemble pour
vivre pour gagner de l'argent pour avoir
de la réussite on n'est pas noyé dans
les pensées de lille hier tu demain
et je pense que c'est dans ce silence
l'introspection quand on est face à soi
même
que naissent les véritable vision
nouvelle
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]